end of the show Esther
she's officially banished she has
banished from the channel from the
whatever banished I
she she's also trying to overtalk me
again she's also been doing this whole
show she's also talked a lot this show
and this woman keeps trying to overtalk
me so I mute her mic she keeps going
and I'm like you know what get out she
refuses to leave so I'm like blessing
called the security from the lobby I
swear to God I would have waited I would
have waited until the show ended and
waited for security to come up just to
go get her
I would have done it on stream finally
this girl leaves a lot of you guys have
expressed concerns stop inviting Esther
back you guys
yeah she's done we're done
[Music]
crazy lady crazy lady